hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to destiny rebellion we're
going into the way of darkness which I'm
just assuming that is gonna be really
bad and scary and inky and dirty I fall
at the same time paradox the least
probable thing happened here a human
from the past and a monster from the
future met in a strange world what lies
in these happenings oh my well that's
not exactly what I was expecting but
this Pleasant nonetheless okay that is a
new sound I have never heard of you
before
or have I maybe maybe I have I have no
idea
clunk nothing wait a minute
Oh am i reenacting Justine right now
whoa what is going on here okay good I
actually have my lantern and it's full
of oil so that means I won't be
completely in the darkness from now on
what are you you're some psychedelic
rock that I've never seen before
oh is that oh this is totally the level
for Justine I know this because I played
it do I need these rocks no I do not oh
I'm sorry I thought you were fake you're
real you're very real oh don't you dare
you [ __ ]
jump heal where's mine
that get I'm good let's go oh my god
CP shifts balls get out of here alright
so now that that crisis is averted kind
of Wow was averted oh wow I've heard a
lot I hope you no need of water yeah
okay take two on that one this time not
dying in a rather spectacular fashion so
I need to find a crib error and
hopefully that guy is burn oh that's a
good sound
oh this is new oh okay
why are they changing everything this is
not how or what am I looking at what is
that
are they stars in the sky can I put away
my lantern because I'm kind of wasting
oil and you're kind of eating Pacific I
didn't mean to complain so there are
three stars in the sky forming Orion's
belt did someone just burped behind me
was that a burp I think it might have
been a burp
hello are you the vortex liquidator that
is a pretty impressive name for a drill
so I'm gonna take my vortex liquidator
along with my oscillating light inducer
known as a lantern and I'm gonna
continue forward
goddamn it again did someone just throw
up behind me is that vortex liquidator
I'm out everybody god damn this gun
funky what was that med kit
[Music]
no one knows I'm here
readings my friend yes it's not what's
meant to be read by you all the time I
knew you will be here I know everything
Ralph's affirmed ight be a friend I knew
from the beginning that you were built
we'll build the time machine and end up
in this world where exactly do you think
you are does this place look kind of
familiar
if you want re-read the notes from the
aristocrat in dere monitor you already
know that this world is superior to any
other dimension indigent bound away out
of the worlds this dark place is
imperfect mirror reflects in a certain
place where most bizarre things were
happening the story was about three men
blinded and tortured because of ill
fated love I know that you will find the
golden key because you were destined to
do but that but beware the twisted
reflections of the unfortunate men the
dark molix are more dangerous and they
look like signed the Harlequin Harlequin
Harlequin alright okay if you say so why
was he there I'm so sorry that had end
like this
I've lost my eyes but my heart still
hurts me the mouse I think it was
supposed to show me something but there
just so happen to be a monster right
blimey that son of a biscuit that son of
a nugget biscuit that son of a nugget in
a biscuit son of an ass ass of a son
okay that's death okay alright don't
jump in the water why would I think why
would I think not to do that apparently
that I am do things that I choose to do
I don't know how about I just continue
forward and stop questioning my own
inane logic that's Riley for the best
okay so this time I'm gonna not fall in
the water I'm gonna not die to the guy
and apparently I missed something oh
this is normal darkness this is advanced
darkness mm-hmm
hi cigarette that's the thing that I
needed
hi mr. spider-man are you gonna hurt me
okay you're gonna hurt me
sorry I'm out of here I don't have time
to deal with you hey wait a minute you
also you're the guy who was burping and
puking behind me the whole time I'm so
sorry for that incredibly important
waste of time and now he dies goodbye oh
that was quick enough of that enough of
that amazing extreme darkness hello
Zarek's troll okay not going that way
not yet anyway okay extreme fire wowee
that was some extreme fire so what's up
there I need there's a way through there
but I'm guessing that there's something
up here that is going to pop out at me
Oh or there's oil which is good I like
oil thank you I needed that and the way
is blocked okay so that's what I thought
that's what I suspected ow
okay continuing on it is dark in here
even my lantern can't light it up oh the
hell I was weird
that's what you gonna do to me huh all
right you're a son of a [ __ ] ain't you
anything up there good God well this guy
god damn this guy put a lot of work into
this extreme darkness y'all y'all y'all
know I'm over there oh that was creepy
remember the brave person is not the one
who has no fear but the one that can
overcome it the brave one is the one
that conquers had all bombastically with
giant tests all right whatever I'm going
forward no time to go back if I need to
go back for something that's obviously
gonna let me know but I have a feeling
that the way might have been blocked
anyway nothing under the stairs oh I
thought that was a person okay the music
kicked up hello oh hi my friend are you
that human they were experimenting with
steroids
you look good okay it's red why is it
red oh this is delightful good god this
is the most trippy son of a [ __ ] hi
hi why am I doing this why am I doing
this
are they trying to get to me so what's
happening are they trying to get to me
I don't know if that's what's happening
I don't know what's happening at all
anyway visitors in the void okay that's
good let's just get a little light up in
here uh yeah that's much better that
feels better
oh that's better what's with all of this
why
okay okay I really did not expect that
ah Jesus
get out of here okay okay I'm going
faster now barely behind me oh you still
cannot feel the presence of the evil
perform the ritual correctly when you
find a golden eagle place it where it
belongs I got a golden eagle number
three I'm slide it was never sorry there
we go
that looks good but one two three one
two four so where my friend Lazar go off
to Lazar mind buddy so that was the way
of darkness I'm guessing that Lazar is
gonna find the last one that I need
that's the forest e area oh hello there
shooting rocket stars whoo thank you for
this medical kit
oh is that another one no that's the
same way okay so I'm now gonna go into
the rocky crevasse what is that holy
crap
Oh what is that hang on there's so many
cool things here I got to see him hello
hi how are you how are you can I climb
up birria there we go oh is that it
is that the only thing dammit I thought
there was gonna be some cool over there
okay what's over here goosh Wow go bye
that's it all right never mind then
I thought that was actually gonna be
something interesting there but never
mind
okay SuperSpeed into the next area I
still got time so I'm gonna just keep
going forward
hello the frozen cavern very interesting
okay into the fall wow this is cool now
this reminds me a bit of penumbra
because the penumbra actually featured a
lot of underground caverns and stuff
like that oh that is tiny bugs Tim if I
ever saw the pulp out of those monsters
I'm gonna carry with you with me forever
and ever we have been expecting you it's
an honor to welcome such a talented
person my colleagues to Harlequin and
dare mountain and in Australia have been
awaiting arrival as much as my
magnificent Highness don't be confused
everything is all right and now it's
foretold long ago now to the point be
sure that the climax in this cave is
really cold I don't think you know what
climax means okay not just from the cold
everything here freezes to the bones
okay anyway bla bla bla
so he told me something important but I
don't remember what
and I wasn't paying attention tiny box
Sam and I are gonna go on another
adventure yeah we're gonna do a great
job killing all these monsters tiny box
em don't you think that's a little bit
violent
hey these bastards deserve it they
almost trapped me before why can't I go
this way
oh no no tiny box Simmons not mailing me
go I think we got to go around
oh wait never mind I panicked for
nothing sorry
that's okay to anybody sim cuz the long
and we're together we're gonna be just
fine
so what am I supposed to do here maybe
there's some way maybe I should have
read the over oh hi I'm sorry tiny
Buxton police protect me
oh okay oh I'm sorry tiny bugs Tim are
you talking to me
are those the mumbles I hear from your
mouth not about Sam I don't think I can
carry you continue oh yes I can because
I am awesome God look at me look at me
I'm so cool god I'm awesome yeah you are
markiplier you're the best
oh thank you tiny about sim I have to
say that to inflate your ego I need to
keep you grounded oh thank you I think
yeah whatever I wear together we're
gonna be fine oh I almost died they're
pieces of snow and ice bhakta way good
amount of heat should melt it how about
all of this Wow
alright then come with me Janna Maxim
we're still going on our little
adventure whoa hello oh hi
lose the statue right good.you you stay
that way
statue don't move
if you do I'll be very upset you're not
moving right good okay we're gonna gonna
camp here for the night that's okay with
me
so I'm on a lot of time for this one so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation to war reduce it I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]